[Musique]
si tu avais pas envie de venir fallait
pas venir en fait parce que si c'est
pour être là et faire la gueule
excuse moi mais ça sert à rien ça
apporte rien de bien ni atwan ya moi n'y
a personne ici ne m'accorde comment tu
peux me faire des reproches alors tu
m'invites à une soirée pyjama rentrer
fille c'est pire que la fredzone ça ça
un hasard si je voulais pas voir je
n'aurais pas invité donc j'ai ton pote
bsc ça c'est pas parce qu'on est entre
filles que c'est une soirée girly
tu vois on est entre personne humaine
voilà il n'y a pas de différence en fait
là on est entre amis entre potes
moi je veux être ton ami camélia kabeya
la scène d'amour qui commence
on peut en parler après c'est n'importe
quoi sérieux pas pourquoi c'est pas
parce que tu fais des guilis à quelqu'un
qu'il envie de t'embrasser ça ne sera
pas de sens mais qu'est ce t'en sais si
je te fais ça tu as pas l embrasser
enfin si je fais ça tu as tu envie de
m'embrasser
non mais ça les regarde non je crois pas
ça je le fais mais juste une question
regardait pas elles m'ont l'air sinon la
paperie m'embrasser
wahou vous faites voilà je sais pas si
c'est comme si je contrôlais plus rien
quoi wayne noémie tu veux venir par la
secte appelée tu sais
des faits des guilis way
si tu fais là je dois savoir aller à
sénat basculé
e défi du coup ce qu'on va faire c'est
que vous allez comme qui dirait pâtir
[Musique]
comment je suis censé vous défendre
après tout ça et diaz c'est le retard de
trop non là on a atteint le point de non
retour
je suis désolé puis les événements va
devoir se passer de vous
la titre personnel ça me fend
sincèrement le coeur
ça vous fait aucun effet ce choix moi je
vous ai vu grandir dans cette entreprise
je me rappelle quand nous sommes enfin
il ya cette attention
écoutez il ya ce jeu peut-être revenir
sur ma décision finalement
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais
non
[ __ ] mais qu'est ce que tu as fait
m'écraser sérieux
la merde
donc tu ramènes ton pote et ça non je
connais pas tu fais quoi là
[Musique]
ça va ah ouais j'ai bien gardé
ouais je passais avait mais je sais pas
en fait j'ai cru que j'avais une sorte
de super pouvoirs comme ça avait marché
sur toi je t'ai pas dit bah en fait non
la fille je lui plais depuis le départ
parce qu'elle a des sentiments pour moi
et qu'elle se dit tiens on s'embrasse et
être ensemble ça pourrait des trucs cool
à temps mais ça ça veut dire que ma part
a pas que ça veut dire qu'ils pouvaient
aussi la pécho du pouf
comme quoi tu vois on ne connaît jamais
vraiment ses amis un tas poste atteint 8
à pâtes oui oui oui
ah ouais on connaît pas trop trop d
[Musique]
il joue peu mais oui si tu cites à demi
nue
[Musique]
oh
c
[Musique]
m
ouais
[Musique]
il faut que ça
vous
à
[Musique]